hey guys i'm ryan right and i'm gerry
today i'm checking out a video with
jerry that jerry has seen before I said
I have to check out this video because
people are asking me but he said he
wants to watch it again so the reaction
part is coming from me and the theory
reactions is a rare yeah it's a second
look is that interesting what are you
action show does that second impressions
all right Mario Kart fury road
here they come again
I'll hear everything hurts
you want to get through this do as I say
yes
oh what a day
ah
good
Mario hmm that video did two things
reminding me how great mad max's and
reminding me how great Mario cut perfect
marriage there was a great really well
edited like the inserts of everything
David did the color changes on their
outfits oh yeah that was really well
done the Mogul the moments were good and
the timing of everything was really
impressive that's like I gotta imagine
where may this was just like a pro on a
day off having fun yeah I like it it's
like a dark Mario Kart movie yeah now I
hope that the next mario kart game at
least has one war rig in it well this
makes me think that if they do a mario
kart movie it should be dark and Syria
dark violent just niall istic you know
with the nintendo world you could
totally do like an avengers thing ok
good i don't know if you can do they
cost extra smash brothers get I just
appreciate the attention to detail you
know because it's like you've got the
rainbow road and then you've got like
that blinking like when you get the
stars and stuff like that and there are
lots of little things that get lost too
and like it's subtle because like that
big sweeping wide shot you can see like
every car is dragging our turtle shells
or balloons is like a really really
great the inserts were flawless I
couldn't even tell somebody like
sometimes you would laugh and then I'd
be like what's he laughing and then I
was catch it and like it was so blended
in well that you don't even notice it
sometimes real good real good real good
anyway guys thanks for tuning in if you
needed the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects jerry has a playlist on
this channel reasons to jerry and you
can follow us on facebook instagram and
twitter or normally i would do a joke
about getting product placement with
enough followers then i make a sex chair
probably gangbang [ __ ] something like
that but today we are going to do a
shout out
John swallow yeah that cannot be your
last day oh maybe it's swallow like like
the bird no those birds are [ __ ] to
you hey guys my name is Shawn swallow
and I just love all you guys please give
me a shout out also John swallow has
left many requests and here's what I
request from you Jones a list of demands
Shawn you have to show us a video of you
swallowing oh and you know I'm talking
about no no one is safe come on let's be
a little subtle today huh what's that
the audience think about what I'm
thinking about of what he will be
swallowing very loose definition or
something jizz your own jizz you have to
swallow your own jizz didn't want that
to get miscommunicated no Shawn swallow
no no what I hope you're not like like
some handicap twelve-year-old good